depuis la reprise de la saison
culturelle en septembre les salles de
spectacles constate une baisse de
fréquentation mais également des
changements d'habitude les abonnements
se font rares des spectateurs achètent
leur place au dernier moment où paye
mais ne se présente pas c'est fragile on
regarde les gens reviennent pour les
têtes d'affiché ça ça fonctionne mais
les gens n'achètent plus haut comme
auparavant avec un abonnement on a pu
d'abonnés voilà c'est très rare
voilà c'est ce contre les doigts d'une
main les gens achètent vraiment au
dernier moment puisqu'ils attendent
vraiment et je pense qu'avec les ce qui
s'est passé auparavant ils ont peur de
se retrouver avec des places
sur les bras si tu as la fermeture des
boîtes de nuit le 10 décembre et face à
la montée des cas du variant au micron
le directeur du théâtre de la mairie se
montre inquiet ce qui nous inquiète
c'est que on a commencé donc
avec cette dernière vague avec la
fermeture des discothèques après les
discothèques voilà c'est quoi ces soins
couvre-feu sur la fermeture des lieux
culturels même son de cloche du côté des
cinémas malgré une programmation riche
les salles sont loin d'avoir retrouvé
leur niveau de fréquentation d'avant la
crise sanitaire -30% par rapport à 2019
des chiffres en baisse avec un même
constat les habitudes ont changé je
pense que les gens ont pris aussi
d'autres habitudes on parle beaucoup du
streaming des plateformes et cetera oui
je pense qu'effectivement il ya de ça
c'est sûr mais les cinémas peuvent tout
de même compter sur les blockbuster
marvel le dernier spider man sorti le 15
décembre a réalisé le meilleur démarrage
de l'année avec 476 mille entrées en
france dès le premier jour on a eu une
semaine comme je te le disais
complètement folle avec spider man qui
est le succès de l'année le buster que
tout le monde veut voir donc là retour
des gens en masse dans les salles comme
si s'était rien passé absolument c'est
vrai une année assez compliqué pour les
lieux culturels qui espère rester
ouverts l'année prochaine la merise a
déjà programmé ses têtes d'affiché comme
tryo ou coeur de pirate et les cinémas
peuvent encore compter sur la sortie du
prochain batman ce crime ou encore les
animaux fantastiques